thank you so I thank you I want to I
want to thank Lenny and I both want to
thank Rob and for and the nexus
Institute which he is for bringing us
here please please join the Nexus
Institute get the bumper sticker join
and keep it alive and because he's
theirs they have so many interesting
ideas and doing a night like this is
completely because of them and and we're
so happy to be here and Shaun is so
awesome it was really such a great night
so for Shaun and Rob and Evelyn and the
Nexus Institute and you all will do one
more little song
was dreaming
in my dream in well of an aspect right
and fair
and my sleeping
it was broken but my dream hit Lincoln
knee
in the farmer
shining Bally's Oh ever pure air
rarefied
my senses
the OPM
I always
into the crime
that the people have the power to
fools
[Music]
the greatest shower its degrees
people rule
at the power
our
people have the power
believe it
aspects became suspect
as 60
Yami's she stood dancing because the
people had their ear
and the shepherds
and the soldiers where they lay they
meet the stars exchanging visions their
armies to waste
in the dust
in the form of shining valleys where the
pure hair rarified in my senses a newly
opened
our weekend
we'll have the power
people have to work
people have a power
[Music]
we're desert assault founders and like
cream the poetess rise nistro's there
together we're gonna laugh or criticize
lady
around
my hope and
I was dreaming in my dream man
I know
you
as I surrendered into my sleep in I
commit my G
[Music]
to tree
two out
to strike
love the power to tree
to wrestle
it's decreed the people rule
people
if everything we dreamed
to pass through again
we
the world
we have the power
hyperpower
the people at the power
people
forget it use your voice
[Music]
[Music]